the solution is to override the
onpostexecute method of the async task
and this runs on the main thread we
receive the string array of forecast
results which came as a return value
from the do and background method above
first we clear the forecast adapter of
all the previous forecast entries then
we go ahead and add each new forecast
entry one by one to the forecast adapter
this is what ultimately triggers the
ListView to update note that if you're
targeting honeycomb devices and above
you can use an add all method here so
you don't have to add them one by one
you can just add it once and update the
ListView once once you hit refresh
you'll see the weather forecast for the
next seven days for your location even
though we hit refresh we don't have any
verbose logging statements being printed
out here we don't need them anymore
because we have a way to check that our
code is correct by looking at the UI now